i think in the in the world of like  improv if people are improvising outside  of the scene  and  they're basically doing stand-up and  they're not throwing it back at you and  they're not building something with you  that's disappointing that's like  all right you don't really need you just  turn to the director like you don't  really need me here because he's just or  she's just gonna you know  do their stand up so it's like i don't  know why i need to be here have you ever  gotten upset well yeah i guess so yeah  and then you just hope  that we don't spend too much time on it  because they're probably not going to  use a lot of it because you want to  improvise  towards the story you really want to  give them things that the editor will be  like that actually serves a story we'll  get